c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir des regrets mais pas
d'excusés le roi des belges en visite à
kinshasa a prononcé un discours où il
exprimé une nouvelle fois c'est plus
profond regret concernant le passé
colonial de la belgique au congo les
congolais eux attendait des excuses nous
serons à kinshasa dans ce journal des
milliers de sénégalais ont manifesté ce
mercredi à dakar à l'appel de
l'opposition ils ont défilé pour
protester contre le rejet de yiwu
askanwi la liste nationale de
l'opposition pour les prochaines
législatives
nos correspondants étaient sur place les
détails dans un instant un programme
d'insertion pour empêcher des jeunes de
rejoindre les groupes djihadistes il a
été lancé en côte d'ivoire par mamadou
touré ministre de la jeunesse de
l'insertion professionnelle et du
service civique il est notre invité ce
soir entretien à la fin de cette édition
rien nouveau dans le discours du roi
philippe concernant les crimes commis
par la belgique pendant la période
coloniale en république démocratique du
congo le roi philippe a exprimé ses plus
profonds regrets concernant se passer
mais la foule venue l'écouter devant le
parlement en attendait beaucoup plus
notre correspondant clément bonne roue
était au milieu de cette foule écoutez
c'était un discours très attendu pour la
première visite du roi philippe de
belgique en rdc de nombreux congolais
voulait que le monarque aille plus loin
qu'il y a deux ans quand il avait
exprimé dans une lettre au président
félix tshisekedi ses regrets pour les
crimes commis pendant l'ère coloniale
beaucoup attendait les excuse peut-être
même des réparations finalement le roi
n'est pas allé jusque là il a simplement
réaffirmé ses regrets mais ce qui est
nouveau et finalement très symbolique
c'est qu'il l'a fait ici à kinshasa au
congo devant les congolais et puis il
est revenu quand même longuement sur le
passé colonial de la belgique en
expliquant que le pays assume et
totalement son passé
avantagé
ep20
l'exploitant
c'est la domination
ce bébé
était ici l'avion illégal
en 3g
vous appelez
les différents tableaux
elle
il a donné lieu
des exactions
et des experts
certains congolais auront peut-être été
déçus mais le message que le roi
philippe a voulu envoyer est avant tout
un message de réconciliation en clair la
belgique n'a plus peur de regarder droit
dans les yeux son passé et elle souhaite
désormais écrire un nouveau chapitre
avec le congo le roi d'ailleurs terminé
son discours en appelant de ses voeux un
nouveau partenariat d'égal à égal un
renforcement de la coopération
bilatérale et il a rappelé également
l'immense potentiel de la rdc
l'appel de l'opposition à manifester au
sénégal a été entendu des milliers de
personnes ont défilé ce mercredi à dakar
contre le rejet de la liste nationale de
l'opposition et yaya scan oui pour les
prochaines législatives une
manifestation également hostiles au
pouvoir la correspondance à dakar de sa
race à coups la manifestation s'est
déroulée dans le calme sans incident
majeur encadré par un solide dispositif
policier les manifestants se sont donc
donnés rendez vous ici place de la
nation à l'appel des leaders de la
coalition y est oui askan wi et la liste
de leurs revendications et longue vie
chère chômage mauvaise gouvernance
système de santé public et bien sûr la
réhabilitation de la liste eh oui
askanwi liste nationale de la coalition
qui a été retoqué il ya quelques jours
par le conseil constitutionnel
je vous propose d'écouter ces
manifestants la devise a donné
mais ça ne
nous dit on de faire ça si on vient de
faire sa maman il ya trop de mauvaises
on peut aider le peuple si le peuple
souffre je souffre et nous voulons nous
voulons nous voulons que le sénégal
comme rompit pas se développer pour des
grands pays émergents sans lui sans
éducation sans la santé sans le 10 ans
allemand terme on en a marre du
président a gelé en 2012 mais il matto
si on n'a pas de porte on n'a pas de
l'hôpital on a pas d'efforts les
principaux leaders de la coalition y est
oui askanwi se sont ensuite adressés à
la foule en fin d'après midi sous les
hourras dont des leaders politiques
comme ousman sonko ou encore barthélémy
dias le maire de dakar se sont adressés
à leurs partisans ils ont promis que la
coalition dit oui askanwi n'en resterait
pas là et participeraient aux
législatives coûte que coûte
la colère des magistrats en tunisie la
mobilisation se poursuit après le
limogeage de 57 d'entre eux pour
corruption et autres délits par le
président accède alors que les tribunaux
sont pratiquement à l'arrêt depuis ce
lundi une centaine de juges avocats et
associations ont manifesté aujourd'hui
pour dénoncer le traitement de certains
juges limogés reportage de nos
correspondants lilia blaise et âme dit
lily
nous avons fait la révolution pour notre
liberté pas pour que les vérifier notre
virginité c'est le slogan de ces femmes
magistrates avocate et militante de la
société civile qui manifestent devant le
tribunal de tunis elles font référence à
deux des cinquante sept juges révoqués
par le président de la république accusé
d'outragé aux moeurs l'examen médical
vérifiant la virginité de l'une d'entre
elles a été publié sur les réseaux
sociaux nous sommes là pour protester
d'instrumentaliser les femmes leur vie
privée
leur corps
aux histoires politiques ce qui a été
fait le fait qu'on sorte les pv en
sortent leur nom leur identité toutes
les données personnelles sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est infect matar est grâce à
rabat à exposer la vie personnelle des
femmes au grand public est ce que c'est
réellement digne d'un président de la
république
dont le tribunal depuis lundi les
activités son tour ralenti en raison de
la grève de la magistrature selon une
avocate l'ambiance de travail est très
incertaine on ne sait pas jusqu'où ça va
aller même qu'on nous en tant qu'avocate
que ça est très choquant
même si le secteur judiciaire a déjà été
en grève en tunisie
cette crise reste sans précédent car les
juges n'ont pas de recours possible
lundi certains se sont mises un sit in
dans le palais de justice soutenus par
des avocats
si on laisse l'exécutif prendre la main
sur le pouvoir judiciaire sur l'appareil
de la justice c'est comme si on revenait
à la période d'avant 2011 on en utilise
et la justice pour éliminer des
opposants politiques la grève de la
magistrature doit se poursuivre jusqu'à
vendredi mais le bras de fer risque de
continuer le président kaïs ayed a
demandé à la ministre de la justice une
retenue sur salaire des juges grévistes
les tensions entre alger et madrid ne
baisse pas d'un cran au contraire
l'algérie a suspendu aujourd'hui un
traité d'amitié de bon voisinage et de
coopération conclu en 2002 avec
l'espagne après son revirement sur le
dossier du sahara occidental pour
s'aligner sur la position du maroc
notre invité ce soir et le ministre
ivoirien de la promotion de la jeunesse
de l'insertion professionnelle et du
service civique mamadou touré il est
avec nous pour nous parler d'un
programme de service civique pour les
jeunes à la frontière avec le burkina
faso un programme lancé à par son
ministère pour éviter que ces jeunes
désoeuvrés ne rejoigne les rangs des
jihadistes merci beaucoup d'être avec
moi aussi éviter tout d'abord pouvez
nous nous décrire un peu ce programme de
réinsertion que vous avez lancée avec
votre ministère mettait en rapport avec
l'actualité sous régionale
le gouvernement ivoirien a décidé
d'anticiper dans le cas de la lutte
contre le terrorisme sur l' approche
sociale les réponses sociales apporter
aux populations qui sont dans des zones
frontalières donc avec des pays comme le
burkina le mali une réponse militer
efficace et à porter actuellement mais
nous avons vraiment tirer les leçons de
ce qui s'est passé au mali au burkina le
président république son excellence
alassane ouattara et le premier ce
patrick achi ont conçu un programme le
plan social du gouvernement qui
accordait nas particulier à ces zones
vulnérables donc c'est à peu près 400 5
millions d'euros qui sont investis pour
désenclaver ces zones où il y avait plus
d'électricité y avait pas d'eau il n'y
avait pas d'école n'y avait pas
d'hôpitaux des zones qui pendant des
décennies ont été totalement délaissées
et vous savez que ceux qui sont jugés
comme des théories aujourd'hui et cela
justement cette grande zone habitée des
populations dans les zones où ils sont
installés et donc l'idée de ce plan
important c'est de sortie ces
populations non de la pauvreté en
apportant l'eau l'électricité
l'école élections des santé et donc le
ministère de la promotion de la jeunesse
a conçu sous l'autorité du premier
ministre un plan spécial pour justement
prendre en charge des jeunes 60 mille
jeunes d'ici trois ans dans toute cette
zone là lieu de perspectives en termes
de formation en termes d'encadrement
dont un programme important du service
civique qui se met en ordre du roi avec
tâte au sein du service civique qui
permettront d'accueillir dès l'année
prochaine quatorze mille jeunes parents
l'idée c'est d'accueillir ces jeunes
leur donner un minimum d'encadrement à
la discipline mais surtout le donner de
l'information améliorer la qualification
en vue de l'insertion des programmes qui
permettront de financer donc des jeunes
dans le secteur agricole et poussé
programme nous sommes soutenus donc pas
la france donc l'afd à travers ce que
moi qui ai le contrat du désendettement
d'où ma présence ici donc en france non
seulement pour contenir les discussions
mais surtout avec mes équipes ou voir un
peu les instruments d'insertion ici en
france pour l'emploi le service civique
français franck foulon terre sont autant
de structures que nous avons rencontré
beaucoup de mon séjour en france alors
vous avez évoqué la situation
sécuritaire
encore d'ivoire quelle est-elle
aujourd'hui si vous vous lancer ce
programme c'est pour justement éviter
que ces jeunes rejoignent les rangs des
jihadistes
il ya la frontière avec le burkina faso
il ya la situation qui s'est dégradée
dans le sahel aujourd'hui quelle est la
situation sécuritaire en côte d'ivoire
est normal nous avons eu quelques
attaques quelques incursions sur tout
aller voir ya quelques années de cela
mais aujourd'hui nous pouvons dire bravo
à nos forces de défense et de sécurité
qui ont été d'une grande efficacité et
qui ont permis de ramener le calme et la
sécurité maintenant à côté de la réponse
militaire pour le présent ouattara il
faut une réponse sociale du plan
marshall parce que madame ce qui est
propre aux 750 euros des motos parce que
c'est ce qui se fait à des jeunes en vue
de les enrouler la plupart des jeunes et
études le monde qui s'enrôlent dans ses
mouvements djihadistes ne le font pas
par principe religieux ils font à cause
de la vulnérabilité économique dans
l'idée c'est de suffisamment anticipé
pour ne pas commettre les mêmes erreurs
que nos voisins et donc 12 super
important qui a le soutien donc de tous
nos partenaires au développement alors
c'est un plan qui qui est important vous
l'avez dit qui a pour but justement de
d'être préventif en revanche la
situation dans laquelle se trouve
actuellement le continent est
inquiétante en raison des conséquences
de la guerre en ukraine la crise
alimentaire plane sur le continent et
elle pourrait plonger dès de nombreuses
populations dans l'extrême pauvreté
c'est déjà le cas d'ailleurs notamment
parce que la crise qu vide est passée
par là est ce que ce genre de programme
est suffisant alors déjà la côte
d'ivoire comme la plupart dans des pays
dans le monde n'échappe pas à cette
réalité internationale mais le plus
important ce sont les musiques ont été
prises le gouverneur ivoirien n'a pas
voulu rester les bras croisés
qu'est ce que nous avons fait
premièrement sécuriser des populations
au niveau alimentaire
donc il ya certains produits de grande
consommation tels que le riz le lait
tels que l'huile et cetera dont les prix
ont été plafonnées ensuite nous avions
tape produits de base nous l'avons
étendue à 21 produits de base dont les
prix ne peuvent pas être augmentés sans
l'accord préalable de l'état
nous sommes un pays comme la plupart des
pays africains grands consommateurs de
pain le gouvernement apporte une
subvention au munier et pour que
justement
la l'augmentation du prix du blé n'est
pas de répercussion sur le prix du pain
ces 10 milliards et 10 millions par mois
de subventions même jeu propre à l'issue
du carburant madame nous avons du mois
de janvier au mois de mai 2 300 millions
d'euros de subventions et pour le seul
mois de juin c'est 80 milliards de
subventions plus du carburant ou du
gasoil à tout ça pour éviter qu'ils
aient une inflation et que ça impacte
les populations et les appauvrissent
alors que c'est une mesure d'urgence
j'ai envie de dire mais est-ce que vous
avez une autre vision un peu plus à long
terme comme par exemple vous êtes
ministre de la jeunesse comme par
exemple encourager les jeunes à investir
le secteur agricole pour qu'il y ait une
suffisance une autosuffisance
alimentaire et qu'il n'y ait pas une
dépendance à des pays comme l'ukraine
pareil mais c'est une orientation
économique avant même connaissait crise
ukrainien la quadrette un pays agricole
nous avons un programme national
d'investissement dans le secteur de
l'agriculture aujourd'hui le
gouvernement de monsieur patrick achi a
décidé justement de faire de
l'agriculture un secteur de portes
unités pour les jeunes et donc nous
avons les sens du service civique qui
seront construits l'ensemble des taux
national l'idée madame c'est
d'accueillir des milliers de jeunes qui
seront accueillis qui seront formés
acquis pour qui des terres seront
aménagés avec la possibilité donc d'une
modernisation de notre agriculture est
ensuite le méthane des intrants entre le
permettre donc d'avoir une actuelle
insectes agricole - ardres - dur parce
que la plupart des jeunes qui refusent
aujourd'hui de s'élancer de
l'agriculture ping donc
[Musique]
la vétusté du matériel utilisé nous
voulons moderniser notre agriculture et
inciter les jeunes à l'éveil secteur
agricole c'est aussi la transformation
de certains produits nous allons nous au
niveau du ministère de la promotion de
la jeunesse nous lancer dans la petite
transformation de leur acabit puisque la
côte d'ivoire en gros pays producteur
dans la cades et permettent à des jeunes
d'avoir des plus unités de
transformation dans la cas depuis
l'ensemble du territoire national merci
beaucoup
mamadou autour ministre ivoirien de la
promotion de la jeunesse de l'insertion
professionnelle et du service civique
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos
questions c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique reste avec nous la faut
continuer sur france inter
[Musique]